first on CBS mornings and we like when
that happens so I'm going to say it
again first on CBS mornings the ride
share company that would be Lyft is
launching new services for customers who
have their own cars even as it faces
economic headwinds the company cut
nearly 700 people that's 13 percent of
their Workforce earlier this month and
its stock is certainly taking has taken
rather beating this year but co-founder
and President John Zimmer is ready he
talked exclusively with our consumer
investigative correspondent Anna Werner
to discuss the new Services the
company's future and its competition
hey I'm John Zimmer co-founder of Lyft
John Zimmer and his co-founders
brainchild the Lyft app provides
consumers with that familiar
right-on-demand service just order a car
and go but now the company wants to
offer the 75 percent of its customers
who also own or lease a car additional
Services right in the app you can now
tap a few buttons and a car shows up why
hasn't that happened for car ownership
you know whether it's you know parking
all in one place roadside assistance all
in one place so with a 9.99 per month
lift pink membership customers will have
coverage for four roadside emergencies
per year and now you can track the tow
truck in real time and arrange for
repairs or maintenance at a shop up
front here you see the estimates and as
Zimmer showed us they'll also be able to
find reserve and pay for parking in a
garage so are you promising that your
prices are going to be lower for parking
or tow trucks that's the plan yeah so at
9.99 to get free tows to get 15 off car
maintenance and then to get discounted
parking it should be over time the the
most affordable way to manage your
vehicle in those early days we were told
we were crazy to think people would ride
in each other's personal vehicles it the
next move for a company that started in
2012 and now boasts of 3.2 billion rides
since then and a co-founder who started
thinking about how to change the way
Americans travel when he launched a
startup called zimride in 2007. we're
trying to make history by building a new
form of transportation but expansion has
its challenges some analysts see Lyft
struggling in the shadow of the gorilla
in the Rideshare industry Uber I do see
right now a tough road ahead for them
Brent Phil is senior Analyst at
financial services company Jeffrey they
don't have uh what Uber has with
ubereats and many of the other product
lines that they have so there's just a
greater diversification of revenue
streams from Uber versus Lyft really
being a one-trick pony that's why he
says lyft's stock price has taken a much
bigger hit than Ubers this year dropping
roughly 76 percent year to date compared
with Ubers roughly 32 percent dip what's
interesting interesting is you have some
analysts downgrading you very recently
here and yet you're smiling and looking
very confident so what's the disconnect
seven years ago
we had five months of cash in the bank
and now we have a much better situation
I'm confident in what we're doing I'm
confident in we've overcome way harder
challenges and I'm excited about the
future so are they wrong
I believe so I mean if they're doubting
uh our ability to to weather any storms
ahead they're absolutely wrong the
storms aren't over earlier this month
Lyft laid off nearly 700 employees some
13 percent of its Workforce part of a
trend of recent layoffs at tech
companies Zimmer says Lyft had to bring
costs down but he says look at how we've
weathered whatever has been thrown our
way and and don't bet against us for CBS
mornings Anna Werner San Francisco
all right John Zimmer he seems to be
saying okay bring it bring it they're
still in business the other thing I just
heard about Lyft is you could they have
a partnership with Delta Airlines yes so
that when you when you get a Lyft ride
you also get miles on Delta I think
that's pretty cool guess who takes
advantage of that perk and by the way by
the way that is the kind of thing which
makes me think I'm gonna do this instead
of that right you know competitive
industry yeah so the more features they
have that helps the customers the better
but David that is a very good perk isn't
it David likes it all right